[Musica]
l'avete riconosciuto esplorando il corpo
umano è stato uno dei miei cartoni
animati preferiti da piccola e la cosa
meravigliosa e che ora lo è per la mia
bimba 30 anni dopo rimi rendo conto di
come questo cartone abbia in realtà
polarizzato i miei interessi e in un
certo qual modo guidato le mie scelte
future sia professionali che di temi di
ricerca
detto questo magari qualcuno di voi
penserà che io sia diventata un medico
un biologo un biotecnologo invece no
sono ingegnere chimico questo è forse
l'identificativo più comune per noi
ingegneri chimici un impianto bruttino
sporco
magari anche circondato da un'aura
minacciosa ma in realtà per noi non è
così per noi è bellissimo perché quello
che ci vediamo sono tutti questi
fenomeni finemente regolati e
controllati che avvengono all'interno di
questi reattori di queste torri
però mi fermo qui perchè prima vi ho
volutamente portati fuori strada ora non
lo voglio fare
vi voglio invece portare a quello che è
stato il tema di ricerca che mi ha
appassionato già con gioia da 15 anni ed
è la ricerca in campo biomedico
guardate ancora per un attimo questa
immagine e adesso guardate questa questa
è una rappresentazione di una generica
cellula animale e umana anche se a prima
vista non sembrerebbe in realtà le
similitudini tra le due sono moltissime
le cellule possiedono il centro di
controllo migliore che noi possiamo
immaginare il nucleo hanno delle
centrali energetiche con efficienze per
noi irraggiungibili sono i mitocondri
hanno delle strutture portanti
fortissime scambiano materia producono
scartano potrei andare avanti per ore ma
evito quello che vi voglio dire con
questo messaggio che in realtà noi
ingegneri che ci vogliamo buttare nel
mondo della ricerca in campo biomedico
non siamo poi completamente pazzi
insomma qualcosa forse riusciamo a dire
quello che vi voglio raccontare oggi a
una breve storia di come la visione del
corpo umano e anche l'approccio alle sue
riparazioni alle revisioni alle
sostituzioni di pezzi difettosi si sia
evoluta nel corso dei secoli grazie ai
progressi della scienza noi di media
riusciamo a vivere più a lungo e come
nell'utopia della fonte della giovinezza
che vedete in questa immagine alle mie
spalle
cerchiamo se possibile di mantenere il
nostro corpo il più sano e giovane più a
lungo possibile
ma come ci siamo arrivati ci siamo
arrivati attraverso secoli e secoli di
ricerche grazie a scienziati illustri
lungo un percorso molto difficoltoso
pieno di ostacoli però grazie a queste
menti illustri questi ostacoli che
abbiamo abbattuti la storia della
medicina ha radici antichissime si parla
di civiltà egizia ma avvicinandoci un
pochino ai giorni nostri andiamo qualche
secolo prima e dopo cristo con ippocrate
galeno rispettivamente loro hanno
rivoluzionato quello che era il concetto
di corpo umano precedente quindi tutte
le teorie divinatorie animiste del corpo
umano e hanno aperto la strada dei veri
e propri studi sulla conoscenza
effettiva dei componenti del nostro
corpo
le loro teorie seppur parzialmente
sbagliate sono rimaste valide fino quasi
ai giorni nostri
fino quasi padova inizia a diventare
centro gravitazionale per scienziati
incredibili che hanno veramente cambiato
il mondo
questo è il nostro meraviglioso teatro
anatomico che ha visto la nascita della
scuola di anatomia padovana la scuola di
anatomia padovana ha portato delle
rivoluzioni e delle scoperte fantastiche
una fra tutte quella della circolazione
sanguigna
questo è un dipinto di vesalio un altro
grandissimo uomo e genio che ha ispirato
la scuola di anatomopatologia padovana è
lui leonardo da vinci qui dove siamo qui
siamo tra il 1500 e il 1700 non siamo
poi lontanissimi dai giorni nostri in
realtà il progresso lo sviluppo di nuove
tecnologie di strumenti sempre più
precisi ci ha consentito di accrescere
ulteriormente le nostre conoscenze fino
quasi ai giorni nostri fine anni ottanta
questa immagine è presa da un articolo
del time magazine 1989 per la precisione
siamo nel pieno dello sviluppo e del
boom tecnologico sembra che
l'automazione possa essere la soluzione
i nostri problemi anche a livello
biologico ecco che quindi nasce l'idea
del robocop dell'uomo automa in cui
parti organiche potenzialmente difettose
vengono rimpiazzate da macchine cose
sintetiche solo dieci anni più tardi in
quindi 99 sempre sul time magazine
assistiamo una completa revisione di
questo concetto quasi a fare eco ad una
frase che a me piace moltissimo sempre
pronunciata da leonardo da vinci che
l'uomo non può pensare di produrre
invenzioni migliori della natura dove
nulla manca e nulla è superfluo quindi è
proprio qui che sta la perfezione lo
sforzo che noi dobbiamo fare è quello di
cercare di mimare il meglio al meglio
delle nostre possibilità quello che il
nostro organismo già sa fare quindi per
poterlo aiutare nei casi in cui
purtroppo a volte non ce la fa da solo a
ripararsi è qui che dobbiamo andare
ed è proprio da qui che derivano gli
anni anni di ricerche che sono nati nei
laboratori che ho frequentato e che
hanno portato allo sviluppo di queste
tecnologie io grazie all'aiuto di altri
colleghi che ho anche la fortuna di
chiamare amici ho fondato un'azienda che
si occupa della produzione di tessuto
osseo ossa a partire da cellule
staminali del paziente
in questa immagine alle mie spalle
vedete un po la ricetta di queste
ricerche quindi noi partiamo vedete da
una tomografia una scansione delle
immagini del paziente dell'osso del
paziente un osso che il nostro paziente
può avere rotto o può essere affetto da
malformazioni congenite o con generi
grazie a queste immagini digitalizzate
noi ricostruiamo perfettamente la
geometria in tre dimensioni dell'osso
originale e andiamo a sagomare uno scafo
un biomateriale che altro non è che un
supporto che consente la corretta
crescita delle cellule a esatta immagine
e somiglianza dell'originale lui serve
appunto come supporto per le cellule
staminali del paziente e da dove
arrivano da un prelievo piccolo prelievo
di tessuto adiposo grasso del nostro
paziente mi raccomando cercate di non
farvi ingannare da cose che si sentono
troppo spesso al giorno d'oggi
questo è soprattutto questo stato
e assolutamente complicato non è
improvvisato è molto difficile frutto di
lunghe ricerche e finemente finemente
controllato detto questo l'ultimo
ingrediente chiaramente l'ingrediente
segreto di tutte le ricette ed è il
bioreattore che cos'è il bioreattore
altro non è che un apparecchiatura che
noi ingegneri riusciamo a progettare e
sviluppare che ci consente appunto di
mimare quello che il nostro corpo
farebbe per nutrire e far crescere
queste cellule quindi fornisce loro i
nutrienti rimuove i prodotti di scarto
fornisce eventuali stimoli meccanici
elettrici e consente appunto queste
cellule di crescere correttamente
dopo 35 settimane di coltura all'interno
di questo bioreattore noi riusciamo a
produrre un piccolo pezzettino di osso
vivo in questo filmato vedete in
immagini quello che vi ho detto a voce
le immagini 3d le cellule sagome amo il
nostro supporto
le coccoliamo il più possibile le
mettiamo nel bioreattore aspettiamo ed
ecco qui il nostro pezzettino dosso vivo
vero non sintetico pronto per essere
impiantato nel nostro paziente che ne ha
bisogno è pronto ad integrarsi con i
tessuti esistenti prima vi devo dire una
cosa in realtà via un po mentito quando
vi ho detto che noi ingegneri che
facciamo ricerca in campo biomedico non
siamo dei pazzi
in realtà un pizzico di follia anche
dentro le mura di un laboratorio
biologico serve non fa male anzi
[Applauso]